sie wollen umweltgerechtigkeit sie
wollen sie jetzt und sie haben
unterstützung omas gegen rechts
eine von ihnen ist angelika matt als
jugendliche hat sie für feminismus
demonstriert jetzt wird die 66 jährige
wieder auf die straße für den
klimaschutz
das sind unsere kinder unsere enkel ja
es ist sollten sich solidarisch zeigen
mit den ideen der jungen menschen und
sie ernst nehmen mit ihren demonstrieren
denn der inhalt ist ja wahr ist ja
wirklich absolut richtig darf etwas
stattfindet im bereich klima hanappi
rott ist 16 jahre alt und sie engagiert
sich bei fridays for future sei es auf
der straße in sozialen medien oder auch
bei politischen podiumsdiskussionen die
unterstützung der senioren findet sie
gut
die ältere generation kann uns
beibringen wie wir am besten an die
politiker in ran gehen sollen und wie
wir am besten was verändern können weil
die haben ganz viel lebenserfahrung und
wissen und ich freue mich immer wieder
von älteren menschen lernen zu können
und wir können älteren menschen zeigen
dass wir noch hoffnung haben und dass
wir was verändern wollen
hanna will dass sich die klimapolitik
verändert aber auch im alltag ist ihr
nachhaltigkeit wichtig
also man kann natürlich aufhören zu
fliegen fliegen ist zum beispiel
innerhalb europas total unnötig man kann
alles mit zügen erreichen
man kann immer fahrradfahren an
stadtauto angelika matt gerat seit 14
jahren nur ein transportmittel ihr
fahrrad
sie koordiniert das projekt klima kiez
kooperationen in einer arbeitsgruppe von
pumas gegen rechts
das heißt wir sehen es als unsere
aufgabe an nachbarn und menschen
zusammenzubringen unter dem thema klima
und auch so ein stück stadt natur in die
bürger hände zu geben und mit
verantwortung zu übernehmen und dafür zu
sorgen dass unsere stadt bunter wird
grün bleibt und auch gepflegter ist dazu
gehören aktionen wie das gießen und
pflegen von bäumen in der nachbarschaft
das säubern von parks oder das
verschönern von vorgärten
ich glaube daran dass ich ein kleines
steinchen wenn ein kleines dominosteinen
dass ganz viele andere steine in
bewegung setzen kann und ich glaube dass
man auf diese art und weise wirklich
etwas bewirkt und machtvoll auftreten
kann und das ist für mich ein gutes
gefühl
die omas und die jugendlichen entwickeln
gemeinsam ideen für die zukunft denn
eines verbindet sie der traum von einem
nachhaltigen und gesunden planeten